having your own studio where you go for
investment what do you mean well you
have your own studio work we put money
into our studio everything we make
everything we make we put into the
studio okay so just like paramount does
so the same way paramount paramount does
puts money into we do the same thing
except it's just he and I and ours is
not as fancy editing Bay's everything
there for color correction things like
we have everything shooting we do sound
we have stages mm-hmm sets a bamboo
forest an old barn what's fascinating is
we both made before we met we both made
movies well we met on on hate crime but
we both were experimenting or believing
in the other model get people to invest
in the movie have the movie be
successful pay them back so we both have
one we owe money on Oh people money on
people that we know not people that are
you know these are the people they're
gonna come back in the suburban that
doesn't work and get in our face we both
have that in our right behind us and it
bothers me knowing that that I owe
somebody money that somebody believed in
me and I have been able to pay them back
yet I don't want to feel that way
anymore so we won't we're not gonna do
that anymore we don't know we haven't
and we won't if we don't have the money
to make the movie we'll either figure
out a way to make the movie for less or
you won't make the movie tender one
we'll make the movie just with the
iPhone then absolutely well we've got
the same cameras we're not going to lose
the cameras right would you have all the
toys now right the cameras are paid for
right so we can still make the movie
yeah
all right what's your next one being
properly insured what are some things
you can advise other filmmakers to
insure their equipment everything is
critical to have insurance I mean
obviously to do a movie we have to have
insurance yeah there's not everyone's so
sophisticated nowadays so I'm not gonna
let you step foot on their property
without having proper insurance so in
that
and there's great I have great old
relationships with that I mean I'm one
of the gentlemen Kent Hamilton I've
known him for since I was 18 years old
in the business and he's still out there
insuring companies and every filmmaker
should have insurance and you can pull
your insurance together I mean that's
you know independent filmmakers really
should pull their relationships and pull
their resources you know that's what
we're doing we're pooling our stuff
together how can they pull insurance
together that's good I didn't know that
you can invite a policy to aware the
policy I'm giving away all my secrets
okay but how we're doing it is that
there are insurance is in his name and
my name and collectively we use it and
then we use it over identified projects
and that's how I've done things before
in the past it makes it more affordable
to a filmmaker
you